why was ronald reagan's presidency so
significant ronald reagan plays an
important role in the modern presidency
for two big things that he did one on
the domestic front
he broke considerably with the kind of
way of doing things in Washington he
basically in response to the New Deal
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and the Great
Society from Lyndon Johnson President
Reagan came in and said no longer is
government your friend in American life
the government is actually the problem
this was the message of his inaugural
address and he broke with the idea that
the federal government through the
application of its resources could help
American life which was a very stark
ideological break with the way the
American government had been going since
the mid 40s and then in foreign policy
his increased defense spending and his
very strong position against the Soviet
Union coupled with a willingness to
actually negotiate with the Soviet Union
which got him a lot of grief from the
Conservatives in his party that both
hardline and ability to negotiate helped
usher in the end of the Cold War